foreign
let's see
that bill couldn't make it in but um we
can proceed
that you know we have enough people to
I mean this is uh this is a incredible
amount of research and very greatly
appreciated I'm wondering Mr chair
um if by the representative Madam chair
ah
bad habits um I'm wondering if um you
know either representative Shapiro or Ms
Dyer could maybe go through some of the
details of it
um and how it applies and how it applies
to retention which was the concern of
well we retained it okay
um I'm trying to figure out no sorry
Workforce retention oh
I was just gonna mention you know just
reading through I mean
um on page three and Christina can walk
us through probably
[Music]
looks like retention begins kind of on
page three
um of the plan
um just page three of the whole
oh I see so of the um right after
um it just talks about
providers report high levels of stress
adverse effects on Mental Health
insufficient educational opportunities
threatening the quality of care and lots
of staff to higher paying jobs that do
not require post-secondary degree
certifications or further education
um
and that and and just walking back a
little bit it just talks about how
that's also limiting the number of you
know children that they can take on of
course
um but that's so that's the only point
on that that I've seen so far but I'm
that particular area that you're
referring to came out of Senate Bill 446
uh so this was in 2022 and then they
created the
um the strengthening plan
and they've received different types of
funding to move forward with initiating
in specifically the retention piece
if you look at the chart that is on page
three
um
the program initiative is the second one
down
and they've contracted with public
Consulting Group
and the purpose is right there a pilot
program to study and assess effective
strategies for staff Recruitment and
Retention
um
and it just gives a high level overview
if if you're interested I can also
forward you the RFP so you get a greater
idea of what the contract looks like
um but they're really in the beginning
stages
I would also say the other thing that
makes this sort of complicated
um
is if you go to the very bottom of the
program initiative where it says Granite
steps for Quality that was the separate
memo that I sent you which I provided to
the special committee on Child Care
where's that again that's the granite
steps for Quality yeah in the packet
yeah the program initiative at the very
last option which would be page four
is the granite steps for quality and
that is something that's been in the
works for some time I don't know if
you're familiar with the
uh it was licensed plus and licensed and
those are their credentialing to allow
providers to get assistance federal
dollars
it's on the the very last it's on page
four at the bottom of the program
initiative page four of the uh chart the
chart well it is technically page four
of the packet
where it says SB 170fn no that's before
that oh so I put a chart in here to put
down some of the more
um the program initiatives and that
one's own it's a front and back we don't
see that you see it oh here it is it's
at the beginning so go to the beginning
it's just the back of
the second page see it at the bottom
okay oh Granite special quality okay
so that program's been around for well a
long time it just has a different name
and in particular that program is
addressing using funds to improve
quality
and so the they're expanding this and
the idea is to
provide incentive to Providers to access
quality which is a different bucket so
to speak so yeah go ahead so I I was
talking to representative Barry uh Barry
about the committee on child care and he
was saying that I'm wondering if this is
what he was talking about so there are
continuing education scholarships is
that what this would be for like for
staff that they have
um
you know for the professionals to go and
just you know keep yes that is enrolled
but the thing with this particular
program is that you have to be enrolled
in in graded steps for equality and it's
not
um it's not required it is optional but
it is provided but on the other hand
I believe that the child care Bureau
also has to make this accessible in
other ways so I don't think I think it's
concurrent okay uh so the availability
is required
regardless of whether they're enrolled
in this program or not so the intention
of this program
is it to improve the overall quality or
does it because it says capacity
building project so so does it have uh
you know a building and a Workforce
retention component to it or is it just
basically focusing on quality control
within the system
so I would say just because I'm not
really able to testify or give any sort
of analysis just based on my position as
a non-partisan researcher but I do have
people who could come in and speak with
you if you wanted to because I I know
several people that have been working
with special committee on Child Care
could answer those questions I'm just in
my current role I'm not able to do that
um could I ask you to clarify something
else if you can do that without
um
being four or against
the next page which is labeled number
two but it's the third page of charts on
the bottom it says it I guess it refers
to a statute 79 534
and that says it talks about a 15
million dollar appropriation
for child care programs I think it does
maybe you can tell me if I'm right or
wrong
um
for the purpose of financing Recruitment
and Retention bonus and benefit grants
for New Hampshire Child Care employers
is
is that what is what it what it says is
that actually what a ship is and is that
have an overlap with the bill that we're
considering because the bill that we're
considering was specifically about
um retention and recruitment
um
subsidies so I can't answer that
question I can tell you that this was in
hb2 and I might direct you to
um
that was my question the DHHS status
report
which may be helpful but otherwise I
that that's not I can't comment on that
okay
so
we've budgeted money for this exact
thing that this bill is for
um it went through in the budget
and there's substantial millions of
dollars of federal relief that's gone to
Providers 87 percent was to the
providers it's we've received 142
million
43 000.
um
since the since 2020 it seems so
I think if we
I don't think I don't see this bill as
necessary with all the other things
going on and all these other
personally
bye
I I tend to con concur um
the this this is a staggering amount of
research and it's very eye-opening and I
think you know speaks to the the
seriousness with which the issue was
already being taken and there's
substantial legislation and big chunks
of hb2 and lots of federal dollars being
committed so I think you know the the
legislation that we had in 566 which is
looking at I thought there was a one
thousand dollar sign-on bonus and a
three thousand dollar retention bonus
after five years I think is kind of too
little too late I think the focus really
should be in what we have here is is my
thought
so
I think I probably in the long run would
agree with both of you that this is
there these are overlapping efforts and
the actual bill was a rather small
effort compared to the amounts of money
and all the different things that are
being proposed
I guess it's hard for me to know that
for sure because
um
this is kind of outside of my wheelhouse
and so like looking at all this stuff
and trying to absorb it is new for me
um is the bill that we were cons we're
here to consider today an ongoing you
know would would provide ongoing relief
and are all these efforts Federal monies
that will go away after the after the
um expect you know expenditure of covid
funds so that's one question
and the other question is
um how much of these funds are going to
pay Consultants to develop a plan versus
actually going to the daycare providers
to provide bonuses for retention and
recruitment
um
I'm not saying I'm not saying that that
means that we should pass this bill I'm
just saying I don't really fully
understand those issues
um
so for example just give you one example
you know the the thing that um Miss Dyer
talked about initially Child Care
Workforce Recruitment and Retention on
the first page
um
the contract there is public Consulting
Group whoever they are and they're going
to get
one and a half million dollars over two
you know kind of to develop a pilot
project so that's different than money
actually go into the daycare providers
to provide bonuses and um for
Recruitment and Retention right now
so I'm not really disagreeing with you
I'm saying I can't understand all the
complexity of it enough to know that
that there's something else in here that
says concrete as the bill we're
considering
does that make an
um I don't know if I'm being artificial
no I understand your concerns perfectly
yeah yeah I I understand that channel
and and I agree with you on that point
there's a study going on but the very
next
part of this chart is actually talking
about uh 1.5 million dollars
um being
allocate over two years to support our
providers and partners
through the granite United Way
um
I so there is money beings
given to Providers to help them in the
in the process of
having been working for a Community
Partners organization that provided
daycare as well as
Head Start services and knowing they had
challenges trying to find Qualified
people like all education
having having money available through
some source to start off with I think is
a good thing and it's it's not
necessarily coming from the taxpayers
it's coming from another source
and I think the study work that needs to
be done is it will help us long term
determine what money needs to come from
the state to help support those
organizations to make sure they can
continue their work because that's the
challenge is is really um and
part of it is is
I know those organizations were
decimated with the covet activities and
trying to rebuild has been a long slow
road so having these and having an
incentive it's now with money that is
available uh and then what can we do for
the future uh is is important
um yeah and I'm sorry but I would just
say having shared a couple of
subcommittees when I came into this
subcommittee I expected to see
stakeholders here because every time
I've chaired a subcommittee and thank
you madam chair for recognizing me but
every time I've chaired a subcommittee
it's been full of stakeholders whether
it was on pfas or the Human Rights
Commission the fact that nobody is here
um from and it was it was just full of
stakeholders tells me that that it
implies to me that those concerns have
been addressed before I would want to go
forward with this I would at the very
least want to hear from them to say
where they see those remaining gaps
quite honestly the fact that this is an
empty room tells me that a lot has been
done to to address their concerns thank
you madam chair Joe
thank you
um
I would tend to agree with you and um
and even more so I spoke to those Prime
sponsor of this bill who pretty much
said what you said he said well you know
also without understanding all the
details of all the stuff he just said
um
representative germano said that well I
just assumed that that's not going to go
any further because
um there's been so much done that's so
much bigger and so much more significant
in the amounts of money
um than what my bill initially talked
about so I don't think so I I know he
doesn't have any expectation of this
moving forward and I guess I just wonder
if we
we have to take a vote on this I assume
so if we were to itl it is there some
mechanism
by which we could
um formal or informal that we could pass
along
um our thoughts to the
um
to the special committee on daycare that
um all the efforts currently being
brought forth are difficult to
understand and it is important for us
well it's important for me that
um
that among all the money going for
planning and one-time monies that there
is um that we support an ongoing effort
to
um
create a program to support retention
and recruitment
um you know a concrete program not one
that's paying Consultants to um come up
with a plan so you know I I would be
okay with
um whatever we would do itl I guess this
recommend ideal as long as we were able
to pass that along to that special
committee that this is an important
issue to us and it's it's hard to know
to what degree it's concretely being
so
I think at this moment I could look for
emotion
Madam chair just it's been a while so do
we do we take a vote here or do we take
okay so and that would just be a
subcommittee recommendation and then
yeah the way I understand it is we we
would vote on based on what the
knowledge that we have read and and
considered we can take emotion and then
and whatever we decide to do that
information will be passed on to the
committee
second
I'll I'll second that okay all in favor
aye
thank you long um before we close
um just like on the I just want to speak
a little bit to this there is yeah
um there are some concrete initiatives
in here and your concern was longevity
um and it looks I just wanted to point
out that it looks like there is
um they're looking at this long term and
there's three phases to this
um the arpa plan
um and they're just starting phase three
and that's all about long-term long-term
stabilization so
we can feel a little better about our
vote
that there are significant Investments
going into this
I would agree
um I'm just going to pass along I'm
going to put a comment on this that we
need to make sure that the
Child Care committee that's monitoring
this stuff needs to continue to Monitor
and if we need to enact legislation at a
future Point
that's something that we can bring back
with that I think we're closed and we'll
have resolved to this I would just like
to thank
um Miss dyer for doing all this work and
um while we might not fully understand
it um at least we had it to to try to
understand it and to understand it in
the future
and it's something that we can bring
back to the full committee as well yes
and I appreciate your work
thank you very much
and I appreciate all of you for
providing your your input as well on it
I think it's it's a good thing we've
done here and we can pass this along and
know that we've addressed the concerns
that the committee had raised thank you
that's one little things
that gives me shortest
retaining build subcommittee I you know
questions give them the given that this
was for the most part a foregone
conclusion was there is there is there
any way that we could have done this
without actually I mean that if we had
so we have a need to do this even though
even if we all felt the same way before
we got here yeah but we don't have to
meet again and again no that's right and
you know even if you didn't agree you
could have met
still good to bring the conversation and
the rationale into why we feel
on a previous committee
there's only two of us so we couldn't do
much of anything but um
Christina was was with us and she made
made